anything worthwhile take sacrifice
effort and time anything it takes a
while having a nice six-pack takes a
while
sacrifice is not eating the food you
want to eat no sodas its water
constantly you know were you growing
your business take sacrifice 90% listen
90% of the things entrepreneurs do who
win big no one ever sees
90% of what entrepreneurs do who win big
no one ever sees so imagine the
recognition you're never gonna get for
90% of things you do no one sees what
time you get up no one sees what time
you go to say no one sees how many books
you read no one sees how many calls you
make in a day no one sees that but the
same goes for the people that don't make
it no one sees that you're not working
no one sees that you took the whole day
off
no one sees that you're sitting home
watching TV no one sees that you're
watching Wheel of Fortune early in the
morning no one sees that you're not
really working that hard no one sees
that only you know that only you see
that but there's a key time sacrifice
and effort there's a patience that goes
with that